Ngoài Mì bài Thamu, các quan kệ chát điều tra công an tình đặt lắt cho biết
Lên vì đăng tầm sự hiểu xử mục đối trường sản xuất gần 2 tạm pháo nổ
vì đâm mê bò bám kính lời trong kệ tế từ đám sắp tới để điều tra về hành đi
sản xuất hành cầm đó là ngôi phòng 2.8 tuy
Đủ tại sã ai bên tình đặt lắt
Chắc điều tra bán đầu, khoảng 30 năm hành hành cầm 2.8
Gió đâm mê và cẩn tiền tiêu xa ra nhân
Nên phong lên mang tím hiểu kết kỹ tạo các loại pháo pháo pháo tuy
B'o pháo pháo chứng
Sau đó phong vào các trường này trên từ đặt mù các bật liệu
Quá chết nhiều bộ tư hình bộ tồng, bộ tồng, bộ dông, bộ gông và các khạp nổ
Phong chết tạo 3 tức nổ tại nhà rãi của 3 điện ử thông bị xa ổ sản ai bên
Sau khi chết tạo 3 tức nổ thành công
Trong đưa một số về nhà ử thương bị lâm, sản ai bên cất dấu trong phòng nổ
Một số pháo còn lại phong để tài nhà rãi cũng có buồn tình bật liệu và quá chết
Bằng các vị pháp nghiệp buồn lưu tương cạnh xác đi sự công an tình đặt lắt tìm tầy phát hiện
Bắt phương, ngăn chẳng những hộ quà đánh kép có thể gà dò kỹ tạo phong nổ
Bất đầu phong khai nhận sản chất pháo là vì đam mê và bán kinh lời trong kỹ kỹ tình bị đáng pháp đời
Tham chắc đưa ở cuộc phong, có man đã thu dữ một phệ tảm tả pháo nổ các hoài có đối trường từ sản chất
Cung nhiều tăng vật, cuông kiên, quá chết có liên quan
Tại nàn công kỹ tạo sự dùng phá nổ không chỉ tài giá bằng chiến các bộ phần tinh gó thể
Mà sống của bản thân, mặc quan tìa lành lỗi đau và gánh đàn cho chà điện và xá hồi
Để hàng chỉ tài nàn đánh kỹ tạo pháo nổ gái ra
Mỗi người dân ra điện và nhặt trường tình có vị pháp chát dụ phong ngừa có nhanh phẩm mình không tự kỹ
Sự dùng các bản phá nổ, có như vậy thì những câu chuyển tài nàn đau lòng thức tâm tạo pháo nổ sẽ không còn sẽ ra